[Music]
just
five years ago it was hard to imagine
socialists winning elections in america
it's the united states the global heart
of capitalism
for a long time socialism was a dirty
word
republicans called everyone from harry
truman to bill clinton
a socialist in a few short years
everything has changed
a lifelong democratic socialist almost
became the democratic presidential
nominee
twice polls show socialism is soaring in
popularity
and a huge number of young socialist
people of color
are getting elected to office socialists
like jamal bowman in new york and
corey bush in missouri are defeating
incumbent congress congresspeople
black and brown working-class socialists
are winning seats in state legislatures
and city councils
and the biggest name in the democratic
party is a latina socialist
from the bronx if you're excited about
creating a society that works for
everyone
you might be inspired by socialist big
victories in 2018 and 2020
and you might be wondering if you too
can become a voice for your community
that's what i'm here to talk about i
teach math at a middle school in crown
heights brooklyn
i'm an activist and a member of the
democratic socialist of america
and in 2020 i became the first black gay
man to be elected a state senator in new
york
it wasn't easy in the democratic primary
i ran against a state assembly person
who was endorsed by the incumbent
i was opposed by the local political
machine but in the end we won with 58
of the vote it took a lot of hard work
but we won
and i want to help you do the same thing
so
here are some things to consider if you
want to run for office as a socialist
first know why you're running for office
most people who run for office either
democrat or republican
run because they have a big ego or they
want a career in politics and it's easy
to feel like
they're the ones who belong in office
but socialists have a different approach
socialism stresses community and
solidarity
you can run for office to help people in
your community people you know
people you encounter every day at work
or in the neighborhood
in my class i had one girl who was tired
all the time
and when i checked in it was because she
was up late because she had to sleep at
her grandma's house
it was obvious she didn't have a secure
place to sleep every night
how could she learn when she didn't have
her basic needs met another student of
mine was struggling and
then one day just stopped showing up a
few days later i got an email from his
mom saying they had to move to long
island because
they were evicted i ran for office
because of experiences like these
i ran to help people like my students
and their families
i knew what our system was doing to
people and how it impacted the ability
of my students to give their all in the
classroom
that leads me to my second point we need
more
working class socialist in office but
you don't have to start by running for
office
i started out by campaigning for
same-sex marriage in new york
i organized rallies for black lives
matter a canvas for alexandria
ocasio-cortez
i worked on access to affordable housing
with the democratic socialist of america
i wasn't new to these struggles by the
time i ran for office
i'd been fighting for years and was part
of a broader movement for justice
movements are made up of activists and
organizers and the best campaigns are
powered by people
you can do an incredible amount of good
by working as a tenant organizer
or contributing to unionization
campaigns even though the media likes to
focus on the big electoral victories
the real progress comes from thousands
of small victories
fought for by people you might never
hear about
over a thousand people volunteered on my
campaign for state senate
and they are the reason we won if you do
want to run for office
consider where you are most needed there
are a ton of really important positions
in local or state politics
that don't get as much attention as
senate or congressional races
but are incredibly influential
judgeships
city or town council seats state
legislatures school boards
positions at the county level so much
power is held in offices
with elections that go uncontested you'd
be surprised how far you can go
third focus on the material issues that
shape the lives of your constituents
socialism is about material change
helping people in real
tangible ways with programs and policies
that ensure everyone has access to free
health care
decent housing and a good education
don't run
on technocratic tweaks be ambitious
campaign on systems that ensure people
have what they need to survive
and thrive talk about the issues you've
experienced in your community
is rent too expensive do nurses and
doctors
not have enough funding do local schools
not have enough money
socialism is also about power who has it
and who doesn't that's why socialist
candidates need to run on structural
solutions
finding ways to bring power back to
ordinary people
talk with people in your community every
day about the problems they face
and the future you want to build
together your single biggest advantage
is your community and fourth
if you lose don't be afraid to try again
in 2017 i ran for city council and came
up short
it was tough but a few years later i
tried again running for state senate and
won
so don't be discouraged if you don't win
in 2018
corey bush ran for congress in st louis
and lost to a 20-year incumbent
two years later she came back and won
socialists are winning elections because
we're focused on creating a system
that works for everyone and because we
recognize that the system today
is designed to benefit only a small
wealthy minority
socialists are winning because we're
building power by working together
day after day and people across the
country are on board
no matter where you live there are
people all around you
eager for change and seeking practical
tangible solutions to the injustices
they face
so my last piece of advice is this
remember that you are not alone
if you're thinking about running for
office as a socialist look for other
organizing groups in your area
and online together we can create a
better society
one that works for all of us i'm jabari
brisport new york state senator
for the grivel institute
[Music]
do
[Music]
you